Börce kemik kadro öğreneceğim. Coğrafya
Kor okuluna YouTube'un en büyük coğrafya
kanalına hepiniz hoş geldiniz. 39 günde
ayrıntılı TYT coğrafya kampımızın bugün
geldik 29. gününe. Bugün konumuz nüfus
piramitleri. Bu nüfus piramitleri
konusunun ne kadar önemli olduğunu
anlatmama gerek yok. Anlatmayacağım.
Bakın geçen sene çıkmadı. Evet ama ondan
önceki senelerde hep bu nüfus
piramitleri ya MSÜ'de ya TYT'de çıktı. E
geçen sene çıkmadı. O zaman bu sene
çıkma ihtimali çok ciddi derecede
artıyor. O yüzden bu konuyu çok dikkatli
dinliyorsun. En önemli konulardan bir
tanesidir diyorum. Ve ne diyorum? Yunus
hocayla bir defa öğren. Bir daha asla
unutma. Zedua ile eğitim her yerde.
Şimdi gün 29
[Müzik]
nüfus piramitleri konumuz. 59. Test
ödeviniz olacak. Bu videonun içerisinde
bu testin çözümünü ben kendim yapacağım
diyorum ve derse geçiyorum. Şimdi geldik
nüfus piramitlerine. Şöyle bir piramit
gibi bir şekiller çıkıyor karşımıza.
Yani bildiğimiz o Mısır'daki piramitler
gibi. Bakın değişik değişik şekiller. Ya
ne hangi mantıkla oluşturulmuş bu
piramitler? Neden böyle bir şeye ihtiyaç
duyulmuş? İlk önce mantığını kavra.
Mantık şu gençler. Bir ülkedesin sen. Bu
ülkenin nüfusunda yaş gruplarına göre
bir dağılım yapmak istiyorsun. 65
yaşında ne kadar insanımız var? 15
yaşında, 10 yaşında ne kadar insanımız
var diye bir dağılım yapmak istiyorsun
ama o dağılımı nasıl yapacağını
bilmiyorsun. Ha bu soruyu sormuşlar ve
aslında o sorunun cevabı olarak çıkmış
bu nüfus piramitleri ortaya. Demişler ki
ya bizim yaş gruplarımız var. O zaman bu
yaş gruplarını yukarıya doğru
sıralayalım. 04 5 9 10 14 böyle sıralama
yapmışlar. Ve en son 90 +'ya
geldiklerinde nüfus kalmadığı için 90
100 yaşından sonra nüfus yaşayamayacağı
için nüfus giderek giderek daralmaya
başlamış ve giderek daralmaya başladığı
için şekil piramide dönmeye başlamış.
Aslında adamların kafasında böyle bir
piramit çıksın ortaya diye bir şey yok.
Adamlar böyle biz bunları sağlı sollu
yaşı ortaya yazalım, sağlı sollu
sıralayalım demişler ve insan ölümlü
olduğu için ve giderek daralmış. Neden?
Çünkü insanlar öldüğünde bakın ölüyor,
ölüyor, ölüyor. Kimse kalmayınca nüfus
piramidinin üst kısmı daralıyor ve nüfus
piramidi ortaya çıkmış oluyor. İşte bu
şekillerin doğmasının mantığı bu
aslında. Yani bize aslında bu piramitler
neyi gösteriyor? yaş gruplarına dağılı
gösteriyor. Yaş gruplarına göre
sıralamışlar. Ben aşağıya baktığımda bir
piramidin alt kısmına baktığımda bu bana
neyi gösterecek? Ha bak 0 04 yaş 5 9 10
14 yukarıya bakıyorum 90. Ha demek ki
aşağıda yeni doğmuş çocuklar yukarıda da
yaşlılar var. Bir piramide baktığında
öncelikli olarak bunu görmen gerekiyor
senin. Bu tamam mı? Tamam. İkinci kısmı
şu an size grafik okumayı yani piramidi
okumayı gösteriyorum. En değerli yer
burası. Aşağı kesimler demek çocuklar
doğumlarmış. Üst kesimler yaşlılarmış.
İkinci kısmı bakın renklerle
belirtmişler. Bu taraftakiler gençler
kırmızıyla pembe ile gösterilenler
kadını ifade ediyor. Mavi ile
gösterilenler erkeği ifade ediyor. O
zaman biz bu böyle bir piramide bakarak
kadın ve erkeklerin nüfus miktarını ya
da oranını bulabiliyoruz. Tamam mıyız
burada? Demek ki piramitlerin mantığı
bu. Piramidin bir de gençler dikkat edin
alt kısmında çizgiler var. Görüyor
musunuz? 0 2 4 6. Bunlar neyi ifade
ediyormuş? milyon. Ha milyon kişi yani 2
milyon 4 milyon kişi. Mesela 59 yaş
arasında şöyle getiriyorum 4 milyon kişi
varmış. Biraz daha yakınlaştırayım ne
gör diye. Başka bir örnek verelim. 2024
yaş arasında 4 milyon kişi varmış. 4
milyon kişi. Anladık mı? Bak demek ki
ben nüfus miktarını bulabildim mi? Yani
baktım ve nüfus miktarını 2024 yaş
arasındaki nüfus miktarını buldum. Ama
nasıl buldum nüfus miktarını? Bana
burada milyon kişi verdiği için buldum.
Bazı grafikler gençler milyon kişi
verir. Bazı grafiklerde buraya milyon
yazmaz. Yüzde yazar. Yüzde yazdığında
sen bu ülkenin miktarını bulamazsın.
Mesela gel bul bakalım. 204 yaş arası.
Geldim. 4 kaç? 4 milyon değil. Bak
milyon vermemiş. %4 vermiş. %4'ü 204 yaş
arasındaymış. Peki bu ülkenin nüfusunu
biliyor musun sen? Miktarı bilmiyorsun.
O zaman kaçın %4'ü? 1 milyon kişinin
%4'ü mü? 100 milyon kişinin %4'ü mü?
Bilebilir misin? Bilemezsin. Ha demek ki
piramitlerde bir ayrıntı var. Eğer ki
bize yüzde verdiyse piramidi, piramit
yüzde piramidi ise o zaman ben buna
miktar bulabiliyor muyum? Miktar
bulamıyorum. Oranını verdiyse miktar
bulamıyorum. Tabii ülkenin nüfusunu da
vermiş olabilir. Der ki yukarıda, "Bu bu
piramit Türkiye nüfusuna aittir. Türkiye
nüfusu da 1 milyon civarındadır." der. O
zaman sen 1 milyon olduğunu bildiğin
için ha %4'ü kaç yapar 1 milyonun?
40.000 mi yapar? 40.000 dersin. İnşallah
doğru hesaplamışımdır. 40.000 dersin ama
bunu verirse dersin. Bunu vermezse sen
hangi ülke? Hadi bul bakalım. Kaç
milyonun %4'ü? Ha demek ki yüzdesel
grafik verildiğinde biz oranı
bulabiliriz. Niye böyle söylüyorum?
Çünkü bize soru soruyor. Sorularda
yukarıda oran vermiş. Şıklara geliyor.
2024 yaş arası şu kadar miktar nüfus
vardır diyor. Bulamazsın. Anladın mı?
Ama milyon kişiyi verirse bize yani
sayıyı verirse, miktarı verirse ben
buradan milyon kişiyi miktarı
çıkartırım. Nasıl çıkartırım? 2024 yaş
arası 4 milyon kişiymiş. Milyon kişiyi
bildiğinde oranı da çıkartabiliyorsun.
Neden? E bu 4 milyon kişi. Bütün ülkeyi
nasıl bulurum burada? Bütün bütün bu
grafikleri toplarım. Bütün ülkeyi
bulurum. Nüfus miktarını. E bütün
ülkenin nüfus miktarını bilirsem e
buradakini oranlarım %5'i yapıyor derim.
Demek ki milyon kişi verdiğinde miktar
yorumu da oran yorumu da yapabiliyorsun
ama oran verdiğinde sadece oran yorumu
yapabiliyorsun. Mantığı anladık mı? Yani
bir nüfus piramidini gördük senin de.
Bir böyle bir nüfus piramidine
baktığında neleri bulabilirsin? Bakın
nüfusun yaş gruplarına göre dağılışını
bulabilir miyiz? Evet. Bak şöyle.
Nüfusun yaş gruplarına göre dağılışını
hem miktarını hem de oranını
bulabiliriz. Neden? Milyon kişi vermiş
çünkü. Ama burası şöyle olsaydı yüzde o
zaman miktarını bulamazdın. Sadece
oranını bulurdun. Ama milyon kişi olduğu
için bu grafik buna göre yorumlayalım.
Demek ki bir yerde yaş gruplarını
bulabiliyor muyum? Ben bir nüfus
piramidinde bulabiliyorum. Nüfusun
cinsiyet dağılışını bulabiliyor muyum? E
bakın kadınlar erkekler bulabiliyorum.
Çalışma çağındaki nüfus e çalışma
çağındaki nüfus neredeydi? 014 yaş arası
neydi? Gençti değil mi? Çalışma
çağındaki nüfus şurada 64 yaş. Şurası
çalışma çağındaki nüfus aktif nüfus
burası aktif. Buldum bak. Yaşlı nüfus
burası. Bak demek ki sen çalışma
çağındaki nüfusu, genç ve yaşlı bağımlı
nüfusu hepsini bu piramide bakarak
bulabiliyorsun ve toplam nüfus miktarını
da bulursun. Nasıl bulursun? Geldim
sildim baktım piramide. Bütün hepsini
toplarsam toplam nüfus miktarını
bulurum. Ama milyon kişi verdiği için
buluyorum unutma. Tamam. Şimdi gelelim
piramitlere. Hocam nedir bu piramitler?
En gelişmemiş olandan en gelişmiş olana
doğru bakacağız piramitlere. Birincisi
gençler, en gelişmemiş olan bir
kenarları içe çökük piramidir. Bu
piramide mantık şudur. Hiç ezberlemene
gerek yok. Bir piramit karşına
çıktığında ilk bakacağın şey yaşlılar ne
kadar, gençler ne kadar? Bakıyorum ya bu
ülkede gençler, gençler çok fazla,
doğumlar çok fazla. Şu aşağının çok
geniş olması bize neyi gösteriyor?
Doğumların çok fazla olduğunu
gösteriyor. Demek ki bu ülkede genç
nüfus çok fazla. Yaşlılara bakıyorum. E
bu ülkede yaşlılar, yaşlılar az. Ha
hangi ülkede yaşlılar az olurdu?
Gelişmemiş ülkelerde değil mi? Gelişmiş
Almanya gibi ülkelerde yaşlılar
fazladır. Demek ki bu ülke piramidi
gelişmemiş bir ülkeye ait. Ve bir şey
daha dikkatimi çekiyor. Bu ülkede
doğumlar fazla mı? Fazla. Ama bakın
ölümler de çok fazla. Nereden anlıyorum?
Bak doğumlar fazla. 8. Bak burası
oransal vermiş. %8'i doğmuş. Bak
doğduktan sonra şu piramit içeri göçmüş.
Niye böyle keskin bir şekilde içeri
göçüyor bu? Şöyle içeri göçüyor. Çünkü
doğanlar hemen ölmüşler. Doğanlar
ölmeseydi gençler. Piramit şöyle olmaz
mıydı? Bak Doğanlar ölmeseydi bakın
şöyle olurdu. Bak şöyle giderdi ama
keskin bir şekilde piramit içeri
göçüyor. Keskin bir şekilde içeri
göçüyor. Demek ki bu bize neyi
gösteriyor? İnsanların
öldüğünü gösteriyor. Yani burada ölümler
de çok fazla. Ortalama yaşam çok kötü.
Gelişmemiş ülke özelliklerini bu
piramide koyabiliyorsunuz. İnsanlar
ölüyorlar. Ortalama yaşam kötü. Doğumlar
fazla. Ölümler fazla. İşte bu piramit
gelişmemiş ülke. En gelişmemiş ülke
piramidi. Bu maddeleri gençler böyle
ezberlemenize gerek yok. Az önce size
gösterdiğim gibi piramitten rahatlıkla
çıkartabilirsiniz. Tamam. Şimdi bu
ülkede bir sorun var. Ne bir sorunu? İki
tane sorun var. Bir tanesi, bir tanesi
ölümler. Çok fazla insan ölüyor. Bir
tanesi de doğumlar. Şimdi ölümleri çare
hızlı bulabilirsiniz. Sağlık imkanları
biraz gelişirse ölümler azalır. Ama
doğumları azaltmak için çok uğraşmanız
lazım. O yüzden buradaki piramitteki
ülke ilk olarak ne yapıyor? Sağlık
imkanlarını biraz iyileştiriyor. Biraz
iyileştirince sağlık imkanlarını ölümler
azalıyor. Ölümler azalırsa ne olur?
Şuradaki çizgiler ne olur? Biraz dışa
doğru çıkar. Değil mi? Daha fazla insan
olur. Ve bakın ölümler azalırsa mantıken
düşünün kenarları içe çökük. Ölümler
azalmaya başlarsa, piramit düzgün
piramide dönmeye başlar. Bu kenarları
içe çökük piramide. Ölümler azaldı.
Düzgün piramide ülke yani şöyle biraz
daha düzgünleşmeye başlıyor. Bakın biraz
daha düzgün piramide geçiyor. İşte bu
düzgün üçgen piramidi. Buradaki mantık
ne? Ölümler azaldı. Ülke yine gelişmemiş
bir ülke. Yine gelişmemiş. Neden? Çünkü
doğumlar hala çok fazla ve yaşlı nüfus
hala yok. İnsanlar hala ortanca yaş
düşük. İnsanlar öyle çok uzun süreler
yaşayamıyorlar. Ha demek ki bu da
gelişmemiş ülke. Az önce gördüğümüz
kenarları içe çökük de gelişmemiştir
gençler. Bu da gelişmemiş bir ülke
piramididir. Bakın Nijerya diyor. 2025
Nijerya. Yaşlı nüfus yok, doğumlar çok
fazla ama sağlık imkanlarını biraz
geliştirdiği için ölümler azalmış. Peki
bu iki piramidi karşılaştırdığımızda
hangisinde nüfus artış hızı daha yüksek?
İkisinde de doğumlar fazla. Hangisinde
nüfus artış hızı daha fazladır? Bu
piramitte, bu ikinci piramitte nüfus
artış hızı daha fazla oluyor. Neden?
Doğumlar fazla. 10 kişi doğmuş. Tamam
mı? Ama burada ölümler de azalmıştı. 3
kişi ölmüş. 7 kişi arttı. Bak ama az
önce kenarları içe çöküp piramitte Evet.
Doğumlar fazla. 10 kişi doğmuş ama
ölümler de fazla. 6 kişi ölmüş. 4 kişi
kalmış bak. Ha demek ki bu piramitte, bu
piramitte doğumlar fazla, ölümler
azaldığı için nüfus artış hızı daha
yüksek. Nüfus artış hızının çok yüksek
olduğu piramittir bu gençler. Buradaki
özellikleri anlattım ben sana burada.
Doğumlar fazladır, yaşlı nüfus azdır.
Piramidi anlatırken sonra bu piramitte,
bu piramitte bir sıkıntı var. Bunu da
çözmemiz lazım. Bu piramitteki sıkıntı
ne? Doğumlar çok fazla. Doğumları
azaltmak lazım. O zaman ne olur?
Piramit. Doğumları azaltırsan bakın
piramidin alt tarafı içeri doğru göçmeye
başlar. Azalıyor doğumlar. Al sana
doğumların azaldığı piramit. Şöyle bak
ne olmuş. Geçmişte üçgenmiş. Son
zamanlarda doğumları azaltmaya başlamış.
İşte bu biraz daha gelişmekte olan bir
ülke piramidi. Brezilya bakın gelişmeye
başlıyor artık bu ülke. O ilk ikisi
tamamen gelişmemiş ülkeler. Bu gelişmeye
başlayan bir ülke piramidi. Biz buna
gençler asimetrik piramit diyoruz.
Neden? Bakın simetriği bozulmuş. Artık
asimetrik olmuş nüfus burada doğum
oranları azalmaya başlamış. Burada nüfus
nereye toplanmış? Ortada aktif nüfusa
toplanmış. Ciddi bir aktif nüfus var
burada. Küçükten küçükten bir yaşlı
nüfus oluşmaya başlamış. Burada artık
gelişmeye başladığı için bakın ortalama
yaşam süresi de uzuyor. Ortanca yaş
yavaş yavaş yükselmeye başlıyor. Ülke
gelişmeye başlıyor. Yani asimetrik
piramidimiz bu. Tamam. Sonra bu
gelişmeye başlayan ülke ya. Şimdi böyle
sen sürekli daralmaya başlarsan tabanın
bir süre sonra ülke artık çocukların
doğmamaya başladığı artık çocuk diye bir
şeyin ortada kalmadığı insanların şuraya
bakın yaş artık yaşlı nüfusun ciddi
anlamda arttığı yaşlı nüfusun ön plana
çıktığı gençlerin azaldığı bir gelişmiş
ülkeye dönüşüyorsun işte bu piramit arı
kovanı piramidi. Geçmişte arı
kovanlarını ağaçların kovuklarına
yaparlarmış. Ağaçların gövdeleri var ya
bakın o gövde gibi arı kovanına benziyor
biraz. Ona benziyor yani biraz
düzleşmiş. Yaşçılar burada fazla. Sağlık
imkanları iyileşmiş. Gelişmiş bir ülkeye
ait. Gelişmiş ülkeye ait özellikleri bu
piramide bakarak söyleyebilirsin.
Doğumlar az. Okuma yazma oranı yüksektir
bu ülkede. Gelişmiş ülke özelliklerini
koyabilirsin buraya. Tamam. Sonra bu
ülkede bir sorun var. Bu ülkede de bir
sorun var. Doğumlar o kadar az ki
çalıştıracak insan bulamıyorlar.
Avustralya. Bakın bu sefer diyorlar ki
bizim nüfusu arttırmamız lazım. Nüfus
artış hızını arttırmaya yönelik
politikalar uyguluyorlar. İşte çok çocuk
yaparsanız vergiden muaf olacaksınız
falan filan diye bir sürü politika
uyguluyorlar ve ortaya bu sefer çan
şekline benzeyen hani Hristiyanların
böyle bir çanı var ya o çan şekline
benzeyen bir piramit çıkıyor. Nasıl?
Bakın ne olmuş. Düzgün üçgen. Sonra
asimetriye dönmüş. Sonra biraz daha bu
biraz daha uzuyor böyle aşağıya doğru.
Burada tam uzamamış. Sonra son yıllarda
nüfus artmaya başlamış. Bu piramidi
kaçırma. Son yıllarda nüfus arttığı için
bakın bu gelişmiş bir ülke piramididir.
Nüfusun son yıllarda artmaya başladığı
bir piramittir. Bu gelişmiştir yani.
Tamam. Evet. Ortalama yaşam süresi uzun.
Yaşlı nüfus fazla. Nüfus artış hızı
düşük ama son yıllarda artıyor. Evet
bunu da söyledik gençler. Bu az önce
anlattığımıza biz demografik dönüşüm
modeli diyoruz. Aslında o piramitler şu
gördüğünüz demografik geçiş modelinin
çizelgesinin piramit haline
dönüştürülmesi. Burada da yine bu o
piramitlerin bu grafik üzerinden
yorumunu göstermiş. Aslında aynı şey.
Şimdi gelelim testimize. Sayfa kaçı
açıyorsunuz? Sayfa 121. Test 59. 1ci
soru aritmetik nüfus yoğunluğu belirli
bir alanda yaşayan insan sayısının o
alanın 100 ölçümüne bölünmesiyile elde
edilmektedir. Buna göre artıda numaramış
ülkelerin hangisinde aritmetik nüfus
yoğunluğu en fazladır? Gençler bakın
aritmetik nüfus yoğunluğu şu demek. Bu
önemli bir bilgi. Ayrıntılı anlatayım
sana. Nüfus aritmetik nüfus yoğunluğu
kilometrekareye düşen insan sayısı
demek. Bizim aritmetik nüfus yoğunluğunu
bilmemiz için iki şeye ihtiyacımız var.
Bir tanesi nüfus ne kadar miktar olarak
ne kadar bunu bilmemiz lazım. İkincisi
de o arazinin ne kadar büyüklükte
olduğunu bilmemiz lazım. Çünkü aritmetik
nüfus yoğunluğu değişiyor. Sadece nüfus
miktarına bakarak bulamazsın. Mesela bir
ülke olsun. Şöyle küçük bir ülke olsun.
Bir tane de büyük bir ülke olsun. Tamam
mı? Bu büyük ülkeye 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 kişi
yerleştirdi. Bakın nüfus miktarı fazla
ve yeryüzü açısından geniş. Tamam mı? 20
kişi yerleştirdi. Bu ülkeye geliyorum. 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10. Bak 10 kişi
yerleştirdim. Nüfus miktarı buradaki X
ülkesine göre Y ülkesinde daha düşük ama
nüfus yoğunluğu Y ülkesinde daha fazla.
Aritmetik nüfus yoğunluğu. Neden? Evet
nüfus miktarı düşük ama arazisi de
küçük. Arazisi küçük olunca nüfus
miktarı oraya kilometrekareye daha fazla
düşmüş. Böylece yoğunluk fazla olmuş.
Yoğunluk farklı bir şey gençler. Nüfus
miktarı farklı bir şeydir. Bakın burada
nüfus miktarı fazla olmasına rağmen
nüfusun yoğunluğu o kadar fazla olmamış.
Demek ki benim nüfus yoğunluğunu bilmem
için arazinin genişliğini bilmem lazım.
Bir de nüfusun miktarını bilmem lazım.
Bakın şimdi buraya arazi o kadar fazla
geniş ki sen buraya ne kadar fazla insan
koysan da yoğunluğun fazla olamaz.
Kilometrekareye düşen insan sayısı az
olur. Kanada'ya bakın. Nüfusu zaten az.
Üzerine bir de arazisi çok geniş. E sen
oraya yerleştirmeye kalksan insanların
nüfus yoğunluğun az olacak.
Kilometrekareye düşen insan sayısı az.
Brezilya'ya bakın. Evet, nüfusu var ama
arazisi çok geniş. O kadar geniş ki sen
buraya nasıl insan sığdıracaksın? Az
insanın, çok insanın bile olsa. Yunus
burayı kes, kes k kes kes kes. Arazi çok
geniş. Kilometrekareye düşen insan
sayısı az. Avustralya'ya geliyorum.
Nüfus zaten az. Arazi çok geniş. E çok
az insan düşüyor kilometrekareye.
Hindistan'a geliyorum. Bunlar arasında
bakın Hindistan. Hindistan arazisi
diğerlerine göre daha dar ama nüfus
miktarı çok fazla. Kilometrekareye düşen
insan sayısı Hindistan'da en fazla
oluyor. Mantık bu. Yani cevap D. Geçelim
diğer soruya. Aşağı haritada ülkelerin
aritmetik nüfus yoğunluğu
gösterilmiştir. Bu haritada nüfus
yoğunluğu 09 arası olan ülkeler arasında
aşağıdakilerden hangisi yoktur? Bakın
ÖSYM bu tarz bir soru 3 sene önce
sormuştu ve bütün öğrenciler şok
olmuştu. Aynı böyle sormuştu. Hem grafik
okuma, harita okuma becerisi hem de
ülkelerin yerini bilmekle alakalı.
Ülkelerin yerini bilecekseniz hiç
kurtuluşunuz yok. Haritayı da okumayı
bileceksiniz. 09 yaş arası diyor. 09 yaş
arasını bulacaksın burada. Ha şu açık
yeşil diyeceksin. Açık yeşil şu renge
göre belirleyeceksin. Sonra ülkeleri
bilmen lazım tabii. Ülkeleri sana
vermeyecek. Vermedi. Geçmişte bakın.
Rusya açık yeşil mi? Açık yeşil eledim.
Kanada açık yeşil mi? Açık yeşil eledim.
Avustralya açık yeşil mi? Açık yeşil
eledim. Moğolistan açık yeşil mi? Açık
yeşil eledim. ABD'ye bakıyorum. Koyu
yeşil ABD 2519. Açık yeşil değil. O
zaman cevabımız A B oldu. Geçelim diğer
soruya. Doğum ve ölüm oranlarının en
fazla olduğu az gelişmiş ülkelere ait
nüfus piramidir. Doğumların fazla
olmasından dolayı ha doğumlar fazla,
ölümler de çok fazla. En fazla hem doğum
hem de ölüm çok fazla. Kenarlar içeri
çöker o zaman değil mi? Doğumların fazla
olmasından dolayı piramidin tabanı
geniştir. Ortalama yaşam süresinin az
olmasına ve yaşlı nüfusun az olmasına
bağlı olarak piramidin üst kısmı dardır.
Doğumların ve ölümlerin en fazla olduğu
piramit kenarları içe çökük piramit.
Geçelim diğer soruya. Aşağıda ABD'nin
2018 yılındaki nüfus piramidi
gösterilmiştir. Bu piramitteki bilgiler
dikkate alındığında ABD ile ilgili
ifadelerinden hangileri doğrudur? Doğum
ve ölüm oranları düşüktür. Doğuma
bakıyorum. Bakın doğumlar düşük.
Piramidin alt kısmı dar. Ha, doğumlar
düşük. Ölümler de düşük. Nereden
anlıyorum? yaşamış insanlar. İnsanlar
yaşlı bakın 80 90 yaşında bile ne kadar
insan var. İnsanlar yaşlı demek ki
doğumlar düşük, ölümler de düşük. Doğru.
Ortalama yaşam süresi uzundur. Bakıyorum
arkadaşım şuraya bakar mısın ya?
Şuradaki şişkinliğe bak. 65 yaş, 70 yaş,
75 yaş, 90 yaşına kadar yaşamış.
Ortalama yaşam süresi burada çok uzun.
Doğru. Ortanca yaş düşüktür. Ortada
kalan yaş. Ortanca yaş. Yaşlı olan
ülkelerde ortanca yaş yüksektir. Bu ülke
yaşlıysa ortada kalan yaş yüksektedir.
Yani o böyle yaşlı ülkelerde ortanca yaş
yüksektir. Düşük değildir. Yanlış. Çocuk
nüfus sayısı 20 milyon civarındadır.
Bakalım mı çocuk nüfus sayısına?
Yakınlaştırdım. Nasıl bulacaksın bunu?
Bu çok önemli bir yorum. Bak bana çocuk
nüfus sayısı dedi. Çocuk nüfus neydi? 10
14 yaş arasına çocuk nüfus diyorduk biz
değil mi? Nasıl bulacağım bunu? Şimdi
014'ün altını toplayacağım. Bana bir de
milyon kişi vermiş. O zaman bulabilirim.
Miktarı bulabilirim. Bakalım. Kadınlarda
04 yaş arasında bir 10 milyon var.
Erkeklerde de bir 10 milyon var. 04 yaş
arası etti sana 20 milyon. İşte 59 yaş
arası da 10 milyon diyelim. Tabii 12
milyon falan da 10 milyon diyelim. Daha
kolay olsun. 10 milyon burada, 10 milyon
burada 20 milyon. 10 144 yaş arası bir
onar milyon daha koyduk. 20 milyon.
Kadını da erkeği de topluyoruz. Sonra
bunları topladık. 60 milyon. Aa 60
milyon civarındaymış. E hani burada ne
diyor? Burada çocuk nüfus sayısı 20
milyon civarındadır. Yanlış. 60 milyon
civarındadır. Yanlış oldu. Nasıl
bulduğumuzu anladın mı? Hangileri
doğrudur? 1 ve 2 doğrudur. Cevap A.
Böyle yorumlanıyor bu piramit soruları.
Nüfus miktarını nasıl bulduğunu da
gösterdim sana. Geçelim diğer soruya.
Demografik dönüşüm modeli ülkelerin
doğum ve ölüm oranlarının yüksek olduğu
aşamadan bu oranların düşük olarak
gözlemlendiği aşamaya geçişini ifade
eder. Buna göre aşağıdaki grafiklerden
hangisi bu dönüşümde nüfus artış hızının
en fazla olduğu dönemdir? En fazla nüfus
artışı nerede? Doğumların en fazla
olduğu yerde olur. Doğumların en fazla
olduğu yer şunlardır. Şuna bakmayın. Bu
son yıllarda doğumlarını arttırmaya
başlamış. Bu gelişmiş ülkedir. Bunun
biraz daha son yıllarda artışı var.
Bakın yaşlı nüfusu fazla. En gelişmemiş
ülke piramitleri bu ikisi. Bu
birinciydi. Sonra da buna dönüşüyordu.
Bunlar arasında nüfus artış hızının en
fazla olan hangisi? Burada ölümler fazla
olduğu için nüfus o kadar artamıyor.
Artıyor tabii ya. Tabii ki çok artıyor
ama ölümler fazla olduğu için şurada
ölümleri azalttığımız için bu B şıkkında
ölümler azaldığı için doğumları da fazla
olduğu için nüfus artışısı daha fazla.
Cevap Bursa geçelim diğer soruya. Aşağı
artada bazı kıtalar numaralandırılarak
gösterilmiştir. Bu kıtaların nüfus
yoğunlukları aşağıdakilerin hangisinde
çoktan aza doğru sıralanmıştır? Nüfus
yoğunlukları gençler. En fazla nüfus
Asya'da. Evet yoğunluk diyor. Arazi çok
geniş ama nüfus da çok fazla burada.
Dünyadaki nüfusun %59'u burada. O zaman
nüfus yoğunluğunun en fazla olduğu yer
de 3 numaranın olduğu yer. Sonra 1
numara Avrupa gelir. Avrupa çünkü dar
bir alandır ve insanlar buraya göç
ederler çalışmak için. Yoğun nüfusludur
burası. 2 numaraya geliyorum Afrika'ya.
Evet burada nüfus var. Doğum oranları da
var ama arazi Afrika çok büyük bir
yerdir gençler. Aşırı büyük. O yüzden
3ünc sırada Afrika gelir. Yani cevabımız
E şıkkı. 3 1 2 geçelim diğer soruya.
Aşağıda demografik dönüşüm modeli
aşamaları numarandırak gösterilmiştir.
Bu aşamalarla ilgili yargılardan
hangisine ulaşılamaz? Birinci aşama
doğal nüfus artışı çok yavaştır. Doğal
nüfus artışının yavaş olmasının nedeni
birinci aşamada doğumlar çok fazla ama
ölümler de fazla. O yüzden doğal
doğumlardan kaynaklanan nüfus artışı
düşük oluyor. Bakın toplam nüfus düşük.
Görüyor musunuz? Doğum oranı şurada.
Yakınlaştırayım. Şu üstü yeşil olan
doğum oranı, mavi olan ölüm oranı. Bakın
arada nüfus artış hızı ne kadar düşük.
Gördünüz mü? Doğru. Böyle yorumlanıyor
bu. İkinci aşamada doğum oranları
yüksek. İkinci aşama düzgün üçgen
piramidi. Doğum oranları yüksek. Bakın
doğumlar yüksekte duruyor. Bak doğumlar
yüksek. Ölümler azalmaya başlamış.
Doğumlar ve ölümler azalmaya başladığı
için nüfus miktarı artıyor. Bakın nüfus
artış hızı yüksektir. Doğru. 3üncü
aşamada kadınların iş hayatına
katılmasının fazla olmasından dolayı
doğal nüfus artış hızı yavaştır. 3üncü
aşama asimetrik piramit aslında. Bakın
doğum oranları düşük ama ölüm oranları
da düşük. nüfus artmış. Yani doğal nüfus
artış hızı yavaştır diyor. Hayır yanlış.
Doğal nüfus artış hızı yavaş değil.
Bakın fazla. 4üncü aşamada doğal nüfus
artışı en düşük seviyededir. Bakın 4.
aşamaya şuraya doğumlar, ölümler ikisi
de düşük ama nüfus artışı da düşük olmuş
oldu. En düşük seviyede doğru. 5.
aşamada doğal nüfus artışı bir önceki
döneme göre artmıştır. Bakın nüfus iyice
azalıyordu. Arı kovanına dönüyordu.
Sonra ülke biraz olsun nüfusu arttırmaya
çalışan politika yapıyordu. Son yıllarda
nüfusu arttırmaya çalışıyordu. Bakın son
yıllarda biraz olsun nüfus artışı
gerçekleşiyor. Bu da doğru. Yani cevap
C. Geçelim diğer soruya. Aşağıda bir
ülkeye ait nüfus piramidi
gösterilmiştir. Bu ülke ile ilgili
ifadelerden hangileri doğrudur? Bakın.
Doğum ve ölüm oranları yüksektir.
Doğumlar çok yüksek, ölümler de çok
yüksek. İçeri çökmüş piramit. Hemen
ölmüş herkes. Doğru. Bu piramitleri
böyle yorumlayacaksın. Ortalama yaşam
süresi azdır. Bakıyorum yaşlı nüfusa
bakın. Şuraya bakın. 45 yaşında bile
insan kalmamış. Ortalama yaşam süresi az
burada. Evet. Böyle piramitlerde gençler
buna hemen bunun gelişmemiş olduğunu
buldun ya. Somali yaz. Somali'ye göre
yorumla. Somali'de doğum ve ölüm
oranları yüksektir. Doğru. Somali'de
ortalama yaşam azdır. Doğru. Çocuk
bağımlı nüfus fazladır. Evet. Bakın
çocuklar çok fazla. Doğru. Yani
cevabımız E şıkkı. Geçelim diğer soruya.
Aşağıda Kenya ve Japonya ülkelerinin
2022 yılı nüfus piramitleri verilmiştir.
Bakın görüyor musunuz? Kenya'nın altı
tabanı biraz daralmaya başlamış ama yine
de doğumlar fazla. Japonya'ya bakın.
Şuraya bakar mısınız garibim ya? Nüfus
gidiyor yani. Elden gidiyor nüfus.
Kenya'da nüfus artış hızı Japonya'dan
fazladır. Evet bakın Japonya'nınki az.
Kenya'nınki çok yüksek. Doğru.
Japonya'daki yaşlı bağımlı nüfus oranı
yaşlılara bakar mısınız? Japonya full
yaşlı dolu. Full yaşlı dolu.
Kenya'dakinden fazla bakın. Doğru.
Ortanca yaş Kenya'da daha azdır. Doğru.
Kenya'da genç nüfus fazla olduğu için
ortanca yaş ortada kalan yaş azdır.
Aşağıda kalır. Ortanca yaş nerede
fazladır? Japonya gibi gelişmiş
ülkelerde. Doğru. Çalışanların yaş
ortalaması Japonya'da daha fazladır.
Evet. Çalışanların yaş ortalamasından
kastımız şu. Mesela ülkemizde
çalışanların yaş ortalaması 20.
Varsayalım. Gençler çalışıyor. Japonya
yaşlı olduğu için çalışanların yaş
ortalaması 40. Yaşlılar çünkü hep yaşlar
çalışıyor. Doğru. Kenya nüfus artış
hızını arttırma. Japonya ise azaltma
yönünde politika izler. Hayır. Kenya'da
zaten nüfus artıyor. Kenya azaltma,
Japonya artırmaya çalışmalı. Tam tersi
yanlış. Cevap E olmuş oldu. Evet,
geçelim. Bitirmişiz. Niye
söylemiyorsunuz? Şu, e, dersin şu
kısmından sonra bir sayfa var burada.
Gelişmiş ülkeler ve az gelişmiş ülke
özellikleri diye. Ondan sonra Türkiye
nüfusunun tarihsel gelişimi geliyor. Şu
aradaki bu kısmı, bu kısmı gençler bu
videoda işleyelim. Test sorusundan sonra
bunu fark ettim. Tam videoyu
kapatacakken bu kısmı işleyelim. Burada
burası önemli. Bakın gençler, gelişmiş
ülkelerin özellikleri, gelişmemiş, az
gelişmiş ülkelerin özellikleri. Bunları
bilmemiz lazım. Bu gerçekten çok
değerli. Neden? Sen bir piramidi buldun
ya az önce. Bu gelişmiş ülke piramidi,
bu az gelişmiş ülke piramidi diye
bulduktan sonra bu ülkelerin
özelliklerini de yorumlayabilmen lazım.
Gençler, gelişmiş ülkelerin özellikleri,
az gelişmiş ülkelerin özellikleri sana
sorulduğunda bunları somutlaman için,
bunun kodlaması şudur, somutlamadır.
Somutlama yapacaksın hemen. Somutlamadan
kastım ne? Gelişmiş ülke ne dedi o
zaman? Hemen buna bir somutlama Almanya
yazacaksın. Az gelişmiş ülkeye ben hep
Somali yazarım. Somalili arkadaşlardan
özür diliyorum burada. Az gelişmiş
ülkeye de Somali yazarım ben. Bu
somutlamayı yaptıktan sonra yorumlamak
çok basit olur. Şimdi burada bir sürü
özellik var. Bunları korkma. Korkma.
Bunları ezberlemeyeceksin. Sadece
yorumlayacaksın. Mesela sana desem ki
okuma yazma oranı gelişmiş ülkelerde mi
fazladır? Az gelişmiş ülkelerde mi? E
dersin ki hocam tabii ki gelişmiş
ülkeler okuma yazma oranı yüksektir. Ha
bunun gibi yorumları göstereceğim sana.
Çoğunu zaten kendinde yorumlayabilirsin
ama bazıları var ki arada bir kere olsun
nasıl yorumlandığını görmen lazım. Bir
kere olsun gördükten sonra yorumlamak
çok basit olacak senin için. Başlayalım.
Mesela hammadde ithal eder. Almanya gibi
gelişmiş ülkeler hammaddeyi alır
dışarıdan alır ithal eder. Yani ben
demiri ham olarak alırım Almanya bunu
işlerim. Sonra satarım. Araba olarak
satarım. Katma değeri yüksek şekilde
satarım. Para kazanırım. Almanya gibi
gelişmiş ülkeler hammaddeyi ithal eder
ama Somali gibi gelişmiş ülkeler
hammaddeyi ihraç eder. Dışarı satar. Ham
olarak demiri alır. Demir olarak
dışarıya bedavaya satar. Almanya'da onu
alır işler. Araba olarak 10 katına, 20
katına, 100 katına satar. Mantık bu.
Bunu yorumlamayı öğren. Elektrik
tüketimi fazladır. Şimdi bu kötü bir
şeymiş gibi algılanıyor. Ya Somalide'de
elektrik tüketimi bilinçsizler ya hani
daha fazladır diye düşünebiliyor insan.
Hayır oğlum Somali'de elektrik mi ne
bilgisayar mı var ya da elektrikli
eşyalar mı var? Elektriği kullanacakları
ne var? Kullan yok ki. Çamaşır makinesi
bile yok. Nasıl elektrik tüketsinler? O
yüzden Somali gibi ülkelerde elektrik
tüketimi azken Almanya gibi ülkelerde
her şey elektrikte çalıştığı için
elektrik tüketimi fazladır. Yine aynı
şekilde Almanya gibi ülkeler daha çok
kitap okur, daha çok kitap basar, kağıt
tüketimi fazladır. Ama Somali gibi
ülkelerde kağıt tüketimi daha azdır. Bu
yorumu rahatlıkla yapabilirsin. Bakın
yapamayacağınız bir yoruma geldim.
Demografik yatırımların ihtiyacı azdır.
Ne demek demografik yatırım? Demografi,
demokrasi, nüfus insandı. İnsana yapılan
yatırım demek okul yapmak, hastane
yapmak. Almanya gibi ülkelerde nüfus
sürekli artmadığı için onlar bir kere
okul hastanelerini yapmışlar. Yenisini
yapmaya gerek yok. Çünkü nüfus artmıyor.
Nüfus artmayınca yenisini yapmak zorunda
kalmıyorlar. Bu yüzden de demografik
yatırım ihtiyacı Almanya gibi ülkelerde
az oluyor. Ama eee Somal gibi ülkelerde
nüfus sürekli arttığı için yeni okul,
yeni hastane sürekli sürekli para oraya
akıyor. Tamam. Eee, gelişmiş Almanya
gibi ülkelerde intensif tarım yapılır
ama Somali gibi ülkelerde ekstansif
tarım yapılır. Ne demeksif tarım? ES
eski diyor bak. Eski tarım eski tarım
yöntemidir ve Somali gibi ülkelerde eksi
eski tarım yöntemi yapılır. Ama intansif
tarım Almanya gibi ülkelerde entansif,
intensif, internetle tarım, modern
tarım, internetle tarım diye düşünüp
modern tarım diye düşünüp Almanya gibi
ülkelerde yapılır diyeceksin. Mantık bu.
Bak bir kere öğrendin ya bir daha
unutmayacaksın bunu. Almanya gibi
ülkelerde insanlar nerede çalışıyordu?
hizmet sektöründe çalışıyordu.
İnsanların %70'i hizmet sektöründeydi.
Ama Somali gibi ülkelerde insanlar daha
çok nerede çalışıyordu? Tarımda
çalışıyorlardı. Başka? Tarım sektöründe
çalışan nüfus oranı düşüktür Almanya'da.
Çünkü makineyle yapıyorlar ama Somali
gibi ülkelerde fazladır. Gelir dağılımı
Almanya gibi ülkelerde dengelidir. Orta
direk dediğimiz bu ortada bulunan
insanlar paylarını alırlar. Ama Somali
gibi ülkelerde gelir dağılımı
dengesizdir. Sadece zenginler para alır.
Almanya gibi ülkelerde kişi başına düşen
milli gelir fazladır. Bunu yorumlarsın.
Ama Somali gibi ülkelerde kişi başına
düşen milli gelir azdır. Ha, Almanya
gibi ülkelerde nüfus artış hızı
düşüktür. Nüfus artış hızı öyle çok
hızlı artamaz ama Somali'de herkes 8
tane çocuk yapıyor. Nüfus artış hızı
fazladır. Eğitim hizmetleri gelişmiştir
Almanya'da, Somali'de gelişmemiştir. Bu
yorumu yapabileceğiniz için hızlı
geçiyorum. Sağlık imkanları Almanya'da
gelişmiştir. E Somali'de gelişmemiştir.
Hocam bu kadar basit. Altyapı Almanya'da
gelişmiştir. Somali'de gelişmemiştir.
Almanya'da insanlar daha çok şehirde
yaşar. Gelişmiş ülkelerde insanlar
şehirde yaşıyordu ama Somali gibi
ülkelerde insanlar şehirde yaşayamaz.
Çünkü para yok. Yani yaşar da insanlar
daha çok kırsaldadır. Kalifiye eleman,
kaliteli eleman, işi bilen eleman demek.
Almanya gibi ülkelerde daha fazladır.
Çünkü eğitimle yetiştirilmiştir. Somali
gibi ülkelerde bulamazsınız. Kalifiye
eleman. Başka? Almanya gibi ülkeler göç
alır, Somali göç gönderir. Almanya gibi
ülkeler nüfusunu arttırmaya çalışır,
politika izler. Somali gibi ülkelerin
nüfus artış hızını azaltmaya çalışan
politika izler. Almanya'da ortanca yağış
yüksektir. Yaşlı nüfus vardır. Somali'de
ortanca yaş düşüktür. Genç nüfus vardır.
Doğum oranları Almanya'da azdı.
Somali'de doğumlar fazlaydı. Almanya'da
genç nüfus azdır. Doğumlar çünkü yok.
Ama Somali'de doğumlar fazla, genç nüfus
fazladır. Almanya'da yaşlı nüfus
fazladır. Somali'de azdır. Ya bunu böyle
böyle hızlı geçiyorum burayı. Bunu
bilebileceğim bir şey bu. Enerji
tüketimi fazladır Almanya'da. Somali'de
azdır. Enerji nerede kullanacak?
Nüfusunu ikiye katlama süresi uzundur
Almanya'da. Bunu bir önceki derste hatta
tam olarak bu iki ülkenin örneğini
vererek yapmıştım. hızlı bir şekilde
nüfusunu ikiye katlayamıyordu. Uzun
zaman gerekiyor ama Somali hızlı bir
şekilde nüfusunu ikiye katlıyor.
Teknoloji kullanımı Almanya'da fazlayken
Somali'de azdır. ARGE yatırımları
Almanya gibi gelişmiş ülkelerde
fazlayken Somali'de azdır. Evet bunun
yorumunu da yaptık. Bunları biraz hızlı
yorumladım çünkü basitti yani senin de
yapacağın yorumlardı. Yapamayacağın
yorumları ayrıntılı gösterdim sana. Evet
bu dersimizi de bitirdik. Türkiye'de
nüfus kısmına geçiş yapacağız. Ne
diyoruz? Seviliyorsunuz. Kömürden elmasa
dönüşebilmeniz dileğiyle.